there is something about the Open Fields
the wild forests and trees the the lakes
and the the quiet and often Stillness
that surrounds it that awakens the
deepest existential questions and
emotions there's a certain poetic
quality to this environment which
reminds us of the transitory nature of
life to maybe speak in Dost terms there
is a certain flow or way of the world
that becomes especially apparent when
we're out in nature which we can then
also um in which we can see ourselves
and our lives reflected we come into
direct contact with both death and
Eternity and experience something like a
boundary between the mundane and
something much greater